started out playing soccer which is my
favorite sports as well but then when
she asked about learning the game of
basketball then I started teaching her
piece by piece since she started
enjoying it and loved it and now she
plays every day and so it's been a joy
to watch her grow Vanessa Bryant shares
a video of her late husband Kobe Bryant
coaching and talking proudly about their
daughter Gigi her temperament is a lot
like mine she's extremely competitive
very fiery and backs down from no
challenge
so she has a mixture she's good mixing
me in a good mix of a mama so that makes
her even more competitive she captioned
the Instagram video with two heartbroken
emojis Vanessa also posted this shot
rocking a Slytherin sweatshirt and
writing quote Queen Mamba Kobe and
Gianna Bryant both tragically lost their
lives along with seven others and
helicopter crash on January 26 Vanessa
showed her immeasurable strength at the
public memorial on February 24th at the
Staples Center in Los Angeles where she
spoke out on the deaths of her husband
and daughter for the first time publicly
just last week vanessa file legal docs
to add her and Kobe's 8 month-old
daughter Capri to the trust Kobe
established to provide for his family in
the event of his death our
responsibility is to always inspire and
try to take some of the life lessons
that we have learned and share those
with the next generation so that they
can start their journey with a lego
earlier this month Vanessa and her
daughters Natalia Bianca and Capri posed
in front of a tribute mural honoring
Kobe and Gigi
[Music]